hey folks Danny here just in one of the
biggest games that's coming out this
year titanfall we almost have it it's
lonely a couple of you know monton and
change away coming out on xbox 360 it's
coming out on xbox one and it's coming
out on the PC as well and one of the
questions people have been wondering is
how exactly because this is an EA game
will you be able to get the game and it
sounds like Vincent pehle may have
spilled some beans on Twitter today yeah
he's been very open with a lot of
information on Twitter he talked about
the the minimum specs that you're going
to need it on pc but the bigger thing is
that it's going to require origin if
you're a steam account holder and you
were hoping to to maybe play this EA
game it's not gonna happen you're gonna
need origin I think that's not a
surprise is it we we expected this to
only be on origin it is an EA game maybe
I've a feeling that perhaps some people
especially because this game is actually
using the source engine might have hoped
that or maybe might have maybe assumed
forgotten that it was in the a publish
game and thought yeah I'll just get this
and the way I wanted the funny thing
about origin I guess is that there is a
sort of a widespread negative
connotation with it and associated with
and perhaps the battlefield 4 situation
or maybe that's just people are
unfamiliar with it in the same way that
people were unfamiliar with steam when
like half like to first game and the
whole thing just fell apart and what do
you think about the fact that titanfall
is only coming out on Origin what do you
think that means really to the game
success on pc well on pc it's i don't
know that it would necessarily hurt it
but steam just has a bigger user base
and especially after battlefield 4
people are a lot more responsive to to
the steam community whereas origin is
still seen as something of a of an
outlier as something that doesn't
perform as well because we also had
SimCity we did really really badly and
when you're gonna have to rely on EA
servers I think that leaves a little bit
of a bad taste in people's mouths versus
steam which is you know they do this
kind of thing all the time and I think
people were just maybe hoping that oh
this is gonna be on Steam and it's going
to be this great multiplayer experience
maybe it'll be on origin too but yeah I
think this is better news for Microsoft
and for people that were may be on the
fence about am I going to get this on PC
am I going to get this on console and we
saw this a lot from some of the
responses that zampella got in his
Twitter people saying well
since it's an origin exclusive not going
to get it on pc but those people might
move over to xbox one or xbox 360 yeah
but of course soon we'll have even more
coverage of titanfall on gamespot com we
wouldn't have to worry about how people
are going to get the game with more what
the game is all about you excited about
something so excited I really want to
get my hands on this myself I mean sure
it's from the guys that did call of duty
previously but the maxine to like
looking at the videos they seem to
change what the game would be about and
i really want to see how that and the
park or elements that we've seen so much
in videos how does that work when you
actually play it i really want to get my
hands on it well Justin if you want
continuing coverage of titanfall and
other video games that are coming out
over the next couple of weeks and months
stick with gamespot acha Oh gamespot
video que